une élection sans surprise ce matin
patrick devedjian a été élu président du
conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
pierre bédier a pris ses fonctions de
vice-président de sept pays qui aura son
siège dans la commune de vélizy symbole
de la jonction entre les deux
départements
on n'est pas encore dans une fusion on
est simplement dans un processus de
rapprochement
nous avons un instrument pour travailler
ensemble et déterminer ce que pourra
être dans l'avenir une fusion si nous
réussissons à la mener à son terme
une création qualifiée d'historique par
son président les 80 membres seront
répartis en 4 collèges élus acteurs
socioprofessionnels personnalités
qualifiées et associations ces
commissions ne se réunion qu'en tant que
de besoin
nous avançons pas à pas avec pragmatisme
et aussi de grande détermination parce
que nous sommes vraiment convaincu que
la région parisienne et dans panel est
en panne de développement économique et
que l'association de ces deux
départements c'est une réponse d'intérêt
général
un rapprochement qui tend vers une
fusion discuté au sein même de la
majorité
ma principale crainte c'est
l'éloignement des centres de décision
aujourd'hui les yvelines wall il y à la
verse haye
la préfecture elle est à versailles
demain si on avait une fusion des deux
départements
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faudra
aller jusqu à nanterre je trouve
contradictoires à la fois d'avoir
augmenter massivement les impôts pour
garantir notre indépendance est ensuite
venir se marier avec les hauts-de-seine
un rapprochement qui a déjà commencé
avant la création de sept pays les
services d'archéologie avait déjà
fusionné
il en sera de même pour le parc
automobile en ce qui concerne les
prochaines réunions aucun calendrier n'a
encore été avancée